my name is Yan heg I'm the lead singer of
The Swedish metal band amanar and I'm a huge
hockey fan I've always loved the intensity
of the game the speed but most of all I love
The Passion of The Players theame they're so
scared NHL players call that chirping I'm in
your kitchen both to your kitchen I'll trip at
you all day but I'm going to teach him how to
sing all right so Marcus great to have you
here yeah it's pretty exciting it's awesome
to be here well so I've seen that you guys you
do a lot of chirping on the ice right a little
bit Yeah from time to time you got you hear
that well I thought I I could help you maybe
bring it up a notch and and really do it the
proper way cuz that's kind of what I do for
a living only a little bit more Viking style
if you say here's what you do markers [Music]
Alo say that was perfect if you can help me
into that that would be huge that' be nice
yeah so just like when you're a hockey player
you have to warm up properly what I try to do
is like I try to relax the upper body let
the belly go little bit and take a couple
deep breaths do it like a z and you use your
diaphragma okay so you feel like you feel like
I get up here a little bit you know so you're
doing like a little you push with the stomach
all right all right I like it then then you can
go into like a more like a to get
the the more the vocal courts and
all like oh God now that's good but obviously
like hockey this thing is only like 50% of the
game the rest is the mental stuff right yeah so
you got to get in the mood so when you're trying
this when you're preparing for game you could
sit in your little corner and go and just try
something when you get upset with something you
can go then when you come to the game you go like
hey ref open your bloody eyes that would scare
the crap out of me yeah yeah now let's let's
try just do a proper scream so what you do is you
release your belly and then push with you somebody
go that was bad eh not bad not bad
that's not bad yeah so let's let's do it
again see we we in the sink we're good I just
need you on the bench beside me though that
would BR my alpha male out you know so also
perfect for if there's a special player that
you feel like you want to get under the skin of
probably TR Maple Le Ryan Reeves they tough guy
Ryan Reeves yeah after the big guy you know
score right after him that's right all right
here's what you do the next time you meet him on
the ice you go like hey Reeves I'm coming to take
you down I got to try it right yeah try it hey
Reeves I'm coming for [Music] you I don't know
I got can't you can't laugh in a trip though
is just going to start laughing it's going to
be bad I I like the part where you're in the
room and you're just I think guys will start
staying away from me just hand me the clear
tape and then leave my stall you know yeah
let this guy take on the all right good luck
in the global series I'm going to watching
and I hope to hear you growl out there on the
on the eyes the fear of the Vikings and your
opponents you're going to hear it you're
going to hear it it's going to freak out
all the way all my teammates so it's going be
good Brant nice to meet you thanks [Music] man